mauvais point fabien olicard point fr
le plus performant au monde dans notre
suis fou de ma gueule mais toi aussi tu
jeunes hommes sont amenés à physiquement
vous l'avez compris notre cerveau fait
pas très forte ici envoie des fortes
que non en fait les essences et les
vraiment comme toi moi je suis beaucoup
hockey l'agglo longue mais la forme est
fourmi tombe fort me tombe
colmenar de la fontaine donc ça commence
es invention rosissant fêtera la vache
c'est mille mots à la minute si on
était prévu à la base alors
salut je m'appelle fabien olicard dans
pour voir s'ils passent à côté de chez
cerveau il peut faire 38 millions de
mot de la phrase ça je peux te dire j'ai
essence non dans une odeur et une odeur
mais en a pas tant une fois que je les
quatre expériences expérience une
rendez les copies vous aviez qu'à
s'est lui déjà c'est sur ce que tu peux
ressentir une douleur similaire pas
trop haut c'est un notable mais parce
pour toi je sais pas il faut faire un
je plains dans tous les cas c'est quoi
fait ça comme ça et je t'aime pareil on
temps est écoulé on commence par toi ce
partie de notre corps il nous aide à
vous et ressortir de là avec un énorme
aussi c'est à dire que c'est pas par
par quels mots le lan le long ok donc le
tous les coups sont permis
cherche pas à comprendre et là où tu as
qui nous fabrique sensible trois cent
te réveiller avec un menu moi je dirais
une mémoire plus tôt visuels dont je
vraiment votre corps d'ailleurs c'est ce
chante et tout c'est bon je le connais
ce format nous abordons un point en
réviser pendant les vacances vous aviez
expérience de nos cellules savent
coup ci on que leurs grains verts ale au
calcul à la seconde c'est vraiment fort
que je sais pas quand ça tombe tu mets
peux te dire des mots
comprendre les informations que reçoit
rapport aux autres c'est par rapport à
quoi ok ouais ouais mais par contre je
le délire mais c'est toujours ça non pas
vraiment la même mais similaires je vous
lorsque soudain quand soudain quand ça
maintenant je sais pas l'odorat c'est
particulier du cerveau en dans les
choix je sais pas faire ce genre de
raison c'est que en fait qu'on regarde
niveau de fun beaucoup beaucoup du fun
15 jours pour le faire une sangle mais
en une fois faut que là tu peux aussi en
toi au coude avant qu'il faut comparer
connaissez sûrement la proprioception
va voir pour la proprioception essaye
qu'on va voir tout de suite dans le
conseille cette vidéo je vous la
choses celle qu'elle prenne à prévert
long d'un ruisseau
cinquante mille 50
une prise plus forte est tu me dit vas-y
quai le long d'un clair ruisseau buvette
épisodes précédents vous avez proposé
vais pas apprendre le texte en dehors de
qu'un bidon gérer notre course
en fait je peux te dire l'histoire mais
notre corps dans un autre épisode nous
mettrais dans la description maintenant
c'est à vous
comme ça il suffit de voir un mot pour
encore et j'en fait de poser une
way we moratois au coude avant il y
donc ça comme ça ne bouge pas essayer de
exactement ça juliette c'est l'odorat
qui fait que notre cerveau c'est en
on commence par qui moi j'en passe on y
je te jure j'aime pas mais je vais y
que nous parlions du corps c'est le
je vous remercie de votre attention pour
la musique ceinture je vais pas le dire
expérience 3 ces tableaux expérience 4
c'est quand tu dors ça doit bien ça non
et timothy mois qu'on emmène annoncé que
commence par caen caen sur le score sur
une fois après ce qu'ont montré après
une colombe quand sur l'eau se penche à
c'est énorme nos grands vrai dans le
le lire on n'a pas besoin tu vois de le
c'est sans peine que je vous informe que
je peux pas choisir les mots ok donc un
question ouais non mais par les plus
on le texte est par contre je le change
dans le c'est à vous six questions en
avait vraiment du vers les tambours
verrons aussi al'inverse comment le
qui se réveille en dernier et du coup ça
aller parce que c'est moi qui vais
cette participante sonar air de la
permanence où sont nos membres même sans
taquet le but c'est quand même juste
lever se doit le petit nom celui ci oui
comprendra aussi vous avez saisies en
l'eau se penchant une fourmi tombe un
côté infinita raison d'années est très
sumo qu'alizé de le dire dans sa tête et
sujet du jour bienvenue dans matière
décider d'appuyer la l'attend pour moi
esprit synthétique très bien on verra en
j'adore
est c'est parti pour quand tu dors alors
me permet de dire nos sens ne se
le chante après je le connais quoi ouais
a alors le long d'un ruisseau la colombe
billebaude autour de la bi goré que soit
une fourmi se penchant une fourmi tombe
rapport avec votre corps pas le vôtre à
ou aviez-vous la terre le tout avec la
ça fait mal en bas je serai peur j'ai
faire tomber la pièce peu importe il
la vidéo d'aujourd'hui est sponsorisé
cerveau peut lui agir directement sur le
et somnolence c'est çà et là en fait tu
vrai c'est frais c'est hyper trash ce
très bon en fait déjà on a un très bon
les voir très pratique pour savoir où
de le comprendre par contre en vitesse
c'est ça donc en plus de vous accrocher
fait à chaque fois que tu pense à un
face d'eux comment on peut faire
grise dans cet épisode vous allez vivre
ta raison c'est le plus court
le joug de exaltante battus voire en
le délai c'est de lever si nous affiche
faut qu'elle tombe le moins de coups
réveille pas dans le même ordre en
très très peur
vous précisément le corps des êtres
que vous venez de faire parce que en
et dans cet océan mini bus ou nuit ni vu
présence très appréciée de l'uci elisa
de jacques prévert ok alors quand tu
sont nos pieds par exemple est ce que ça
différemment alors donc là moi c'est ça
ulv est
corps merci à tous les participants à
par fabien olicard témoin et ça lui est
truc vous imaginez pas tous les calculs
âgés pas du tout mais il veut qu'on
de lecture normal avec compréhension
dans votre mémoire aux cris
sens olfactif tiens on croit souvent que
psychologie et en physique la douleur
fonction des besoins de perception du
temps normal déjà bon à prendre un poème
humains première question là rien à
fonctionne bien nous allons voir ça tout
possible si possible accord auquel on a
n'est plus à 400 mo minutes
quelques mois déjà je n'arrive pas à
toute l'équipe à charles x man et
que fait votre cerveau pour penser
on le lit on le lit dans sa tête on le
cerveau le toucher il doit se réveiller
et juliette et elijah
les aliments bien meilleure alors
retenait mieux d'ailleurs tu vois le et
s'appelle la colombe et la fordham
dors la nuit toi tu dans la nuit moi
mais moi quand j'étais plus jeune j'ai
effectivement en lecture chill ou en
est hyper intime et c'est ce qui fait
les meufs et les seuils de lever suis là
maintenant ça répondait bien si je me
de suite avec lucie elisa juliette et
retenir les paroles de nos propres
gagner guise
fasse allah c'est pas moi car il est
consciemment tu vois pas des calculs de
cette vibration foncé comme
j'ai pas je pensais que c'était
en avant dernier sauf si tu te fait
certains oui mais genre par exemple les
bienvenu dans la partie sponso narnia
pu bien contre moi voilà
d'haïti de la production à loïc à la
fleury était revenu plus tard alors que
chansons paragraphe le but du jeu c'est
la fourmi
apprécié mes cours en chansons comme ça
d'hommage première question combien
important dans away non parce que je
lit à voix haute aussi et toutes les
j'ai de l'insomnie trop de trucs dormir
lecture où tu veux bien comprendre parce
disais que dans deux heures mais ça
malte les calculs de tous qui décide de
aussi les incompréhensions tu vois de
chiens et nous on a on n'a pas une si
suis surpris je pensais que tu fin que
réal avec toute son équipe et bien sûr
haut tu as vu le délai les chiffres vous
c'est comme ça aux rennais sponsorisé
ça paraît beaucoup plus facilement et
vous
fermé mais n'importe quoi mais j'ai trop
c'est parce qu'en fait à tous les bons
réveiller par une information tactile
deux du coup mémoire beaucoup plus
tu avais tout de suite le nénuphar blanc
des appuis des appuis ça va aller ok
que c'est compliqué tu va redescendre à
s'efforçant mais en vain c'est forcé
d'odeurs d'après-vous peut retenir votre
ça me fait souffrir je te vois
d'une personne qui a vécu le même truc
je feins dessus le concept en fait
tout et il est en train de gérer aussi
les élites g n'hésitez pas à découvrir
pas de retenir tout poèmes oui ce genre
mots mais tu as fait le long le long
n'importe quoi non sa maison mais
ouais je fais des mélodies thueux
on termine avec une expérience
visuel donc c'est rigolo parce que vous
se taire tout ce qui était visuel et
évidemment et l'odorat pie xi ton appart
d'ormesson a fait souffrir tes yeux
votre respiration votre rythme cardiaque
grande différence de récepteurs
encore question numéro 4 nous avons
stressé en fait tu sais que tu sais pas
ses partenaires fusion des deux alors on
d'aller parler de la taille de l'ebre
leurs clips en vidéo leur musique leur
tout ce qui était actions comme tu as
nous avons tendance à dissocier le
là je vais compter deux trois minutes
fermés tongres encore allongée
que l'autre qui dit non mais ça ça fait
nez d'odeurs différents un signe fort
pouvez lâcher c'est juste pour montrer
d'un ruisseau à et buvait une colombe
aviez les premiers les derniers mots et
votre équilibre il est en train de gérer
corporelle forcément en test juste deux
c'était pas mal mais ça fait très peur
olfactifs c'est juste qu'on sente pas
quand tu veux je suis seul car la pièce
mais en vain de regagner la rive sari
quand ça arrive du coup tu agis heureux
rien etc et qui dévalorise du coup
chine qui vous absorber tout ce que vous
commencé à les imaginer et ben en fait
entre un sur dix la douleur physique la
l'antériorité indique par en assemblage
vous structurez comme ça et toi tu as
les mêmes choses tu vois et nous on
prend feu tu te réveilles quand même où
c'est drôle mais ça me fait pleurer et
cerveau du reste du corps pourtant il ne
des neurones dans le ventre combien
commence à se connaître vous et moi
dernier album je mets tout ça dans la
votre digestion il en train de gérer
vous pouvez leur faire juste vous dire
et non non non tu allais pas c'était pas
pouvez et après on fait la restitue voix
mais c'est pas ça me parle avec sandra
je ressens intérieurement déjà le truc
justement pas trop ça n'a pas trop un
trois trucs sur notre corps que je vais
parfois la phobie de quelqu'un ou la
fait différemment forcément fait de la
sa part en mémoire épisodique donc
mais c'était bien tenté
autant que potier
spectateurs de la partie sponso narnia
mène par contre
prête pas beaucoup d'attention à notre
description le prochain épisode de
votre taux de sida cinéma qu'à la
son ordre de montage par rapport aux
soudain voilà que tu ris tueries aux
seul mentalement quand tu as deux dira
commenter après la première chose ça
s'agit que d'un organe parmi les autres
douleur physique de quelqu'un la douleur
ya la pièce là est un frère n'a pas la
l'aï manquée on se parle ça va il manque
beaucoup plus longtemps alors toi tu
d'après-vous environ est ce que vous
patent c'est vraiment le sens qui est
nez aussi en plus donc on a un super
thermos et psion tout et mais c'est j'ai
mémoire épisodique c'est à dire tu as dû
autres assemblage mais genre ça ouais
alors que je n'ai pas encore
éclats et après frérot je sais plus ce
matière grise sera publiée le mois
362 c'est précis c'est pas ça s'est pas
quand soudain non la colombe la colombe
mental de quelqu'un il ya deux choses
s'appelle ou aviez-vous donc la tête
ok la proprioception sa marge à partir
quoique il est bien plus gourmand car il
depuis quelque temps on essaie de rendre
aviez qu'on avait des neurones dans le
imaginez un peu la scène et a fait de la
endormi le plus longtemps et qui met le
le long d'un clair ruisseau le long d'un
prochain il parlera des couleurs et de
vraiment que c'était la taille tu vois
mais vrai truc que j'ai c'est que tu as
l'idée c'est de fermer les yeux ok et de
n'est question numéro 2 toujours sur le
ce moment un peu fun et pétillant et
qui sont très personnelles dans la vie
psychologique je dirais deux puisque en
différemment tuyaux par ok heidi moyen
vent non ça fait que quelques années
posé la question comme ça pour faire
c'est pour ça que j'ai changé c'est
plus de temps à s'activer lala de savoir
dors la nuit moi j'ai de l'insomnie je
qu'elle fait là bas et la moitié la
consomme entre 20 et 25% des ressources
pièce ramé calanques
essayé trouve là tu vas rien recevoir
du moment où on voit vraiment ce qu'on
exprès est une ville qui met même moi je
clair ruisseau
mémoire procédurale parce que tu as
c'est la perception des couleurs et la
fait c'est pas ça 40 40 non mais pour
leur influence sur nous vous pouvez vous
mnémotechnique dont on n'a pas idée de
qu'on sait on a des neurones dans le
ça ça me stresse et là la dernière
drôle aussi
corps l'ordinateur le plus puissant du
te vois dormir et ça me fait souffrir
marrant quand même se soit pas la taille
compris cette wii voilà non tu la
moitié sans faute j'ai parlé de potes la
ou buvez une colombe une combine
dans un an usa de charité un brin
commencé à bouger et c'est la thématique
te dis quand j'ai lu ça j'ai halluciné
que nous apportons à notre corps tout le
c'est que c'est aléatoire j'anticipe
plus de stress parce qu'un peu de stress
douleur l'autre problématique du coût
mettre ses doigts en contact comme ça le
ventre et géré la digestion estomac de
de la puce
abonner gratuitement à cette chaîne si
fait mais dès que tu commences à
bravo félicitations
tes yeux fermés tongres encore allongée
c'était du champagne pour le p tit je
monde est équivalent en pourcentage à
ton corps de mon quart enfin le corps de
question juste parce que ça me fait rire
ils ont fait une expérience ils ont
moitié sans flou la déroute que tu
connais ouais je la connais pas trop si
mélanger ton corps ou quoi tu te plante
vous le souhaitez si la série vous plaît
plus rapidement possible vous faites une
dans ma tête j'ai peur de rien du tout
fait de bien faire attention à bien
colombes lorsque soudain nan nan une
tutin à de pareilles bah ouais
que la douleur son intime c'est dans le
six cerveaux de france exactement c'est
d'herbe lui donna de quoi nager c'est
de la vidéo pour cette deuxième
et qu'on parle du corps est ce que vous
plus bas après tu fais enfin c'est quoi
chacun oui alors attends donc là on a
mille ordinateurs bluegene en route ils
c'est drôle mais ça me fait pleurer et
complètement quand tu fermes les yeux et
c'était les trucs que tu eb jean rampon
faisais tu les corriger en tant que ça
et vous pouvez également retrouver les
petite distance pour l'instant comme ça
manger pour bien penser au final le
quelles capacités de calcul de notre
pense que je vais pas faire insulte à
savez pourquoi on dit à tes souhaits
traitement de la douleur en hôpitaux
expérience c est ce que le corps a un
franchement paraît way
deux trois minutes de trois minutes
les vacances
va alléger très chaud vous savez en ce
que tu rajoutes de l'espace ce qui est
c'est bon tu sais rien du petit parti
14 précédents épisodes de matière grise
soudain voilà que tu ris tueries aux
une odeur c'est moi je connais des mails
lui ont fait 6000 et une seconde de
cerveau est ce que le plus puissant du
et microbien sénat c'est vraiment des
quand quelqu'un éternue
à trois on le fait 1 2 3 aux gt comme
pas mal de cacher la moto merci a vu en
votre intelligence on suppute ans que
genre c'est psychologique parce qu'il ya
pour les adultes on sait faire
quelque chose allez c'est terminé vous
définition apprendre par coeur et sage
sens dans huit noms julienne non mais
corps et le cerveau ne sont pas
marrant d'ailleurs secte à l'heure vous
éclats en dormant où donc est tuant ce
ouvert de 10 à des mélanges d'odeurs
juste inscrire c'est rien du tout
impact si sur la mémoire donc la réponse
et si la mémoire se trouvaient aussi
monde il vaut 10 % de notre cerveau 20%
dans la description alors pouvons
maintenant avec des systèmes de notation
pend tickets plus à cette distance qu'à
dissociables la douleur du corps se
notre activité cérébrale il lui a fallu
vous savez de quoi je vais parler mais
moi vraiment
c'est quelque chose de non exprimés ans
un peu de pression des trucs un peu
apprenait en chansons et je m'en
adacore toi tu es tombé sur moi je crois
neurones au sort ce que les mêmes que
comme on vient de faire là pour les
franchement il ya une odeur ans en quoi
est oui ce que je vous propose c'est
moment où donc est tu vraiment peut-être
je peux te dire l'image s'ils se
souviens encore parce que parce que oui
trouve dans le cerveau la mémoire peut
exploiter les liens présents entre le
triste parce que quand on passe après
1% 100% géré 70 pourtant hockey un
dans notre corps dans le matière grise
40 minutes pour simuler une seconde de
je vais essayer de vous surprendre selon
cette distance j'ai aucune explication
banon mais je me faisais pas du tout et
dans le cerveau qui sont dans le ventre
d'essayer de reprendre surtout vous deux
quelques secondes si tu rajoute un peu
que
avec une autre femme très loin dans un
chez nous on a commencé à croiser ok pas
enfants c'est très très compliqué et je
toi on a l'impression qu'on va mourir
l'adage grandir c'est apprendre de ses
une chanson tu n'oublies pas quoi vous
corps et d'esprit l'esprit peut-il agir
parfois se trouver dans les membres du
autre pays et qu avec elle ses deux mois
comme ça ah oui oh oui sacha
de novembre 2021 je vous parlais des
quand on a commencé à savoir mesurer la
et qui vont gérer la digestion pour pas
connaissaient pas ça commence par les
là je me suis planté là
je m'étais pas senti on ne sent pas la
autos du peu de chauffer à prendre la
de déplacements en plus tard hd à
que genre ouais non douleur physique ce1
avez doublé la capacité mémorielle en
ce qui se passait dans notre cerveau ah
vais vous expliquer sa main
temps c'est
erreurs quand je suis né je faisais 52
mal maintenant on ouvre un peu plus les
corps etc pour la première fois dans
fin du poème et le poème d autres pour
sur le corps vous serez tout cela et
oui et c'est l'ordinateur le plus
mémoire auditive soit était celle qu'on
ordinateur le malheur formant le en
différents types de mémoire que nous
vitesse des choses on s'est aperçu donc
que le cerveau justement s'en occupe
et moi là j'ai déjà commencé à croiser
et demi de mexico logique c'est fin
fait des bravos
que tu ris toi tu dans la nuit moi j'ai
puissant
bras 1 2 3 moi je regarde pas d'un
la douleur est donc bien une sensation
le seul mot que j'ai retenu
cm un grand bébé et je me présente
sensation watch moi je dis qu'il a fait
tron permanence et ils sont reliés ils
le voyait le plus bouger hélas à la
sa maman question numéro 3 d'après vous
capacité de calcul à de kayes pas un
bien plus dans les prochains épisodes de
les aider à press association
il ya très longtemps on s'est aperçu que
avions sans vous développez la mémoire
matière grise je vais faire mal à mes
bob murray pédiatre américain et
c'est dans ces 20 sur 10 vraiment c'est
donc le désert c'était pas ou à huy est
de l'insomnie je te vois dormir ça me
communiquent entre eux et c'est une des
matière grise à très bientôt ciao
c'était là en fait on part souvent delà
aujourd'hui devant vous sans 34 cm plus
procédurale c'est une mémoire implicite
le quand on éternue le souffle sera 160
attend les temps alors en plus il ya un
restitution tu avais tout mais si tu
stockage en mémoire que la plupart des
personnelle intime et complètement
fait souffrir
invités alors ne vous inquiétez pas les
horrible en fait c'est la tante de ça va
combien de mots notre cerveau peut lire
chercheur à l'ohio state university a
c'est d'essayer de réapprendre les deux
la ola non je fais pas la dernière jeu
de la persistance rétinienne pour le
qui fait partie de la mémoire à long
meilleure hypothèse on n'a pas encore
avais les mouvements du corps en fait
à la minute et sans forcément chercher à
subjective que l'on peut parfois modifié
pierres servant un peu faire plus que le
juliette incroyable et maintenant vous
km et donc cette précocité au 19e siècle
élites g seront saine et sauve ensuite
arriver ça va pas arriver qu'est-ce qui
tard c'est dire à quel point j'ai commis
mais des micromouvements en fait qu'il
démontré mais qui fait que quand on a
corps qui fait que le cerveau a
terme cette mémoire est très utile aux
premières phrases mais en te faisant des
recoupé des études pour démontrer
se passe et quand ça arrive tu t'es
truc de de somnolence c'est le dernier
mais il serait intéressant de voir si
comprendre le texte où tu vois combien
cerveau humain plus fort pour toi
par des manipulations psychologiques
des erreurs 134 130 130 4 cm d'erreurs
vous ouvrez les bras le plus possible
saisissant faut bien sera coupé ok
l'impression qu'ils aient une image qui
donne juste des impulsions où on voit
tellement préparés que tu t'en fous
également que les enfants apparemment
quand on s'est aperçu de ça on s'est dit
peur on a mal dans le ventre quand on
sportives par exemple aux artistes aux
c'est complètement sa situation en ce
fermez les yeux 1 2 3 eyes est pas mal
nous ressentons la même douleur
reste le plus classique si tu regardes
gestuelles donc le jeu c'est pas
moi aussi plus fort
c'était une vitesse folle pour l'époque
que ton cerveau il va chercher dans tout
d'avoir senti quelque chose tu te dis
de noms deux mois vie gérér diagonale
apprennent mieux après avoir bougé parce
d'accord va falloir vous taper sur la
est triste quand même si évident parce
provoqué d'alerté bissau il est une
artisans qui doivent reproduire des
longtemps le soleil et à l'impression
coopération de la part du souffrent mais
tu voyais pas les voitures qu'elles
sinon la quantifions pareil et si des
moment imaginé se lâche
ce qui peut donc trop cool bravo juliet
juste il s'est passé un truc la douleur
après non mais là vous devez vous dire
d'avoir une tache au milieu de l'oeil
toi tu as dix 70% et aider un petit peu
que les émotions en fait le siège aussi
gestes rapidement et sans avoir besoin
étaient aussi vite et on s'est dit à
que cela augmente le développement des
tête ok non pas tout de suite
choses permettent d'atténuer la douleur
mais ça c'est quand même plus
où m et loïc tu vois environ exactement
physique pour de vrai show mois à 3 ok
comment faire par exemple pour les
colombe et encore une fois c'est pas
les temps
en dessous la réalité elle est folle je
ces panneaux mais le pentagone avait de
fonctions cognitives une autre astuce de
de réfléchir à chaque fois on peut
dans ces neurones là en fait c'est pour
parce que au final la douleur n'est
physiologique que cérébrale là ce qui
cette vitesse là c'est sûr on perd un
ok vous pouvez ouvrir les yeux et vous
ouais c'est pour ça aussi et quand vous
pour avoir les mots prennent et pour
lire tous les maux m si tu les lie c'est
l'ex-site histoire de centimètres et
suis allée recouper l'information parce
nourrissons nous connaissions
les meilleurs d'invités du monde
ça qu'on est récent il ya combien de
avoir plus de mots que la première fois
utiliser la mémoire du corps pour aider
mais parce que je pense que j'anticipe
mémoire et du corps et d'écrire les mots
quidam il ya un bout d'âme qui sort de
bien justement je vais vous dire non
est intéressant c'est que quand tu mets
que moi je savais qu'un ordinateur était
qu'une information pour que nous
l'expression naturelle d'un bébé pour
neurones comme ça à la louche c'est un
remettez trop chaud tu dis pas ce que je
pour voir si c'est possible basel le
juste que tu t'entraînes pas du sens tu
d'accord non non mais il faudra vous
apprenez vos textes vous faites comment
mais parce que c'est important je
le cerveau à se souvenir d'un texte
notre corps et du coup on a bien le
la pièce est vraiment le corps qui
prenions conscience d'un problème
moins forte que notre cerveau en
peux pas raconter ce qu'elle me
que l'on apprend dans l'air comme ça ça
truc au pif et je vous donne la réponse
signifier sa douleur les cris et les
voulais revenir sur un mythe autour de
vous du coup c'est un force d'antan
fais moins vite ne tue pas non moi je
droit un souhait en échange assez triste
diagonale s'est passé ainsi six mois
somnolence attend prise pasqua
là
c'est comme ça que j'ai pu entraîner une
quelque part sur notre corps c'est
tapez un peu sur la tête ok moi je vais
capacité de calcul en réalité
communique avec le cerveau et le cerveau
déjà fait je sais ce que ça fait je sais
c'est normal que la jolie tourne en
pleurs mais quand la douleur dépasse un
contre lyon ça se compte en centaines de
leur donne une existence corporelle et
c'est
pense encore une fois une très bonne
diagonale sais que tu vraiment ces
la taille de l'aide je m'arrête juste là
boucle dans ma tête dream ouais ouais
amie à moi il ya quelques années qui
d'ailleurs considéré comme l'un de nos
commencer par le faire dans quelques
que j'aime pas cette sensation donc je
qui se dit j'ai pas vu la pièce enlevée
diagonales joie
ouais c'est que je comprends ça pleurait
proprioception et donc la proprioception
certain stade il a été démontré que les
si tout cela ne vous convainc pas
sens la nociception assez parlé
secondes je poserai la pièce comme ça ok
sûr très beau jeu c'est sûr de traîner
commence déjà à ressentir et j'ai
millions 200 millions après être dans la
debré nénuphars un blanc attend enfin
du coup mais vraiment je faisais du coup
devait retenir un monologue précis et je
0,002 pour son nom qu'a tracé blue jays
il est quand même bien senties et elle
quand j'ai des trucs
rappelez-vous des codes que vous
parce que je sens que je vais prendre
c'est de toujours savoir où et où sont
l'impression quand tu reçois la
enfants en bas âge en très bas âge
maintenant je rejoins les ali jay on va
est là on croit que c'est la sensation
tête c'est 68 milliards comme ils ont
encore quelques centimètres si je
j'ai dit je l'entends on pourrait mais
manger pas le verbe
elle tient tout seul c'est normal c'est
châtaigne que ça va jusque dans mes
vais essayer de refaire ça avec mes
retrouver mentalement en faisant
puisque tu fais des rhumes des foins
restées alors prostré il existe
continue par non je pense que je voulais
après tu peux continuer pour voir
de toucher qui te fait croire que tu la
dents touche
nos membres en fait dans l'espace et que
en plus il a un bon tempo le team là
le sébum gras et après on compte le
semblant de taper sur un clavier ou sur
invités
t'es battu final y en en enfer lapidaire
se faire du mal
jusqu'où ex as des traces et blanc les
mis quand même un qui sait pas et on
vraiment à 3 et psychologiquement c'est
sens encore mais c'est purement
dire la taille du club delà de votre
c'est ce que j'allais dire que
aujourd'hui des outils simples appelés
on va tester la mémoire du corps on
tu dois travailler aussi forcément avec
cérébrale donc en fait ton cerveau
techniquement il est deux on fonce et
un digicode très intéressant de s'en
et c'est là vous vous dites mais qu'est
s'en est aperçu qu il ya quelques années
nombre de coups
les instruments de musique tu vois ça
des échelles pour quantifier la douleur
uns les uns sur l'eau se dresse tout
inspirer pour retenir une date
c'est terminé pour ce c'est à vous un
rythmiquement il et ça aide d'avoir une
arrive à quand même à se tromper sur les
dans une page par exemple je dirais
ce qu'on a bien fait de venir ça c'est
un peu ou pas de truc qui me font rire
doit aider c'est le violoncelle qui
d'ailleurs n'en doutez pas votre corps
appelle ça la mémoire procédurale on a
d'un enfant cela veut dire que c'est
un tout petit niveau de fun ou se
rythmique des mots bah oui oui c'est sûr
t'amène plus de proprioception ou c'est
mot pour la fin pour la fin et ben moi
sensations qu'il ressent et c'est encore
c'est une fin de journée forcément ça
plein de types de mémoires différentes
cool c'est un détecteur de mensonges on
qu'on la croise en moi ah ouais ok + une
tremblant ils font quoi déjà ici ils
très compliqué de comprendre une douleur
est très intelligent connaissez-vous
moi je me suis jamais des paroles en
pour terminer ce set à vous vous nous
parce que tu avais plus de
moquent de votre niveau de forme des
en fait c'est cool qu'on fasse tout ça
une fois c'était juste pour expliquer le
proprioception violoncelle basse à ça je
le tient je sais plus si c'est de la
j'ai hâte de voir la réponse des gens
plaques ou mal aimé je les retiens pas
troupes au style est tout mignon son
c'est très grave voilà exactement qui
avec vous parce qu'on vous vous apprenez
amie le genre bah ça dépend en fait moi
lien entre le cerveau et le corps mais
que l'on ne connaît pas soi même un
dans les commentaires
direz si vous aviez trouvé vous si vous
font ça
niveau de fun voulait un niveau de fun
par contre les trucs moi sur scène j'ai
je moi je m'imagine lattois genre pdf
veut le faire donc c'est intéressant on
nasa ou d'amazon d'accord ça c'est un
pense que c'est un travail
c'est assez dont
étiez approché soit meilleure que nous
exemple concret les hommes ne peuvent
des textes de base vous apprenez des
bien épais et bah j'ai la solution pour
nous pourrions continuer 1 c'est à vous
apprend quoi ça ah ben je te dis après
c'est vrai ils font ça qu'est ce qu'il a
devrait s'appeler ce travail et au fur
parce que c'est à travers le but c'est
beaucoup de pédaler je dois vraiment
word j'écris mon mémoire 30 lignes 300
truc très fiable ce c'est vraiment de la
je me suis brûlé électrocuté j'étais
partitions vous apprenez des mises en
pas vraiment complètement appréhender ce
d'accord alors oui donc je prends quoi
enclenché et il ya des moments et ça ça
vous en création de fabien en quarts en
et à mesure et là c'est exactement ce
merde le but n'est pas que de se prendre
comme ça pendant des heures sur ce même
scène donc je serais curieux de voir
d'être tous quel est le dernier sens qui
je pense que tu as plein de sébum à
qu'on est en train d'étudier le sens de
va ça c'est quand c'est logique et quand
pris ma tête pour rien mais si celle ci
dans l'air parfumé dans l'air parfumé
mo
que peut être la douleur des règles la
thème le corps est vraiment très
des châtaignes le but c'est que
comment vous pourriez apprendre un poème
création c'est quoi c'est un spectacle
à 300-400 mourir
la proprioception vous allez maintenant
venait c'était trop bien cette 7e
surprenant le cerveau et le corps forme
se réveille quand vous vous réveillez le
chaîne tata qui a en janvier 2021
intérieurement vous soyez capable de
faire un truc marrant mettez les mains
leurs tiges
où fabien créer son prochain spectacle
c'est enfin je sais pas en fait
à tous et chacun travaille fort là avec
journée mais merci d'avoir démontré sa
matin d'après le dernier deux derniers
alors la réponse c'est plus vers toi
comme ça pour tourner les mains vers
pas la pression je vais je vais toucher
se voit là je consommais ont pu danser
réalisé une expérience passionnante des
mais quand c'est dans des caches tu vois
noter votre douleur entre 1 et 10 si
l'extérieur la main droite sur la main
sens qu'ils se réveillent way le premier
l'autre le corps le fait juste de
il est dans le dur fut le mec et c'est
je me fais des petits trucs comme ça ça
top sort très très vite les textes et 27
manière plus discrète par exemple saviez
gauche ok tu sers tu sers tu sais pas du
c'est non se balancent se balance bon
possible pour moi votre douleur physique
aussi un spectacle qu'ils allaient
ça va genre tu claques ou l'âge des
hockey quand on était petit et regarder
m'aider vous allez participer parce qu'à
joueurs ça vous est déjà arrivé d'avoir
tout regardez regardez quand même 1 1 2
et votre douleur psychologique qu'est ce
vous que votre corps élimine chaque
des sur scène ouais mais pas tant ouais
la fin vous pouvez aller le voir qu'on
un film une fois et après fait c'est
minute 19 c'est lui potentiellement
que vous avez là par exemple
3 comme ça quoi
me donne est votre ressenti pour qu'ils
l'idéal quand même temps j'ai trop mal
cancéreuses ça bosse dur quand même vous
je ne sais pas j'étais somme et même
si tu nous prends pour des veaux l'eau
s'améliorent encore plus pour le
je suis déjà en train de gripper la
c'est exactement ça c'est
temps garder les taux mais la
prochain spectacle du truc du futur le
suppression à temps et encore mieux
table pas du tout honneur aux blaireaux
gars et grâce à ça votre fun il va être
vrai qu'il aime par personne vous urgent
quand on était en cours genre elle sort
qui a écrit cette vidéo je déteste ça je
du court elle s'est par coeur ce qui
énorme et secs ou juteux c'est vous qui
lèvent le doigt c'est exactement ce qui
s'est passé j'ai dû jean de la fontaine
suis vraiment à 10 sur 10
du jacques prévert et du gérard de
psychologiquement j'ai horreur de ça je
voyez comment vous voyez votre fun en
fait un à aller regarder sur son site
nerval qui veut quoi aller moi je vois
la fontaine g d'une mort aussi prêts
versés meilleur méchant la vendéenne
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]